good morning everyone or afternoon I
don't know where it what time is it
wherever you are here currently it is 5
32 in the morning and I am super excited
for today's video because this is very
special to me this channel has been
growing steadily and first of all I just
want to say thank you for your support
but I thought it would be a really fun
way to do like a q a get to know me kind
of video but also as a way to connect
with you and really get to know you so
if you have any kind of videos that you
would like to see and anything that kind
of pops up just put it down in the
comments and we can chat together so I'm
really excited about today especially
though because there's a lot of really
good questions and specifically on time
management I'm really excited to get
into that so without a further Ado let's
get on with today's video the first
question is one that I am actually asked
a lot and so I thought I'd take a fun
spin on it and ask you the question
instead and that is where do you think
that I am from go ahead put your guests
down in the comments I'm curious to know
what you think
did you do it yet okay well I currently
live here in the USA I am a U.S citizen
however I was born and raised in Mexico
when I was a child right smack in the
middle of nowhere
was that your guess up until I was seven
I lived in an area of poverty where most
people did not have running water AC or
Heating and really things like
microwaves and refrigerators were
unheard of I don't remember a whole lot
about my childhood but I am grateful
that I grew up poor because it really
helped shape me and it gave me a greater
gratitude for the lifestyle that I get
to have here in the USA and just the way
that I can also teach my children as
well but what about you where are you
watching from let me know down in the
comments below greetings from the USA
the next question is what do I do for a
living I think that some people might
think that this question may be dull or
superficial but for me it is a very
important question actually because I am
a home hospice nurse that means that I
work with patients that are end stages
of life and my entire job is to help
manage their symptoms so that they can
live their best life for as long as they
have while also giving the family the
resources they need to be able to take
care of their loved ones while this job
can certainly be difficult on an
emotional level I think that for me it
motivates me to live all the more
because of the fact that I am constantly
faced with patients that are dying it
really helps remind me that my life is
ever passing and that I should take
advantage of the time that I have and
really Savor each moment to be a better
wife to be a better mother to be a
better friend and just really value my
time so much more it really makes me
want to be present and Savor each day
next up human brother asks how do I
manage work and YouTube first of all
thank you so much for your support and
thank you for this question because I am
very passionate about work life balance
so I will try not to rant on this topic
because I am sure I could devote an
entire video to this topic so I will try
to keep it to the main three points so
by now you know that I'm a full-time
nurse but I also have a four-year-old a
one-year-old and as you can see I have
this YouTube channel as well so when it
comes to work-life balance I've
developed a few rules that really help
keep me sane so that I can be the best
version of me to those around me because
I work as a home nurse and I work off of
my personal phone having the ability
disconnect from my phone is crucially
important because I constantly get
threads of messages from co-workers or
even my boss asking if anybody wants to
work overtime and it may sound really
rude but I silence those and if I'm
doing something when I'm not working I
turn my phone off and I think that
having this rule for myself is immensely
important because it creates this
barrier like this is me time you don't
pass this threshold and if you don't
respect your time nobody else is going
to do it for you so find whatever
barriers that you need because it can be
really easy to let work creep home with
you if you let it so the first tip would
be is to separate work from home and
find however best that would work for
you secondly is that I wake up between 5
and 5 30 a.m almost every day I have a
full video on how to wake up at 5am
feeling glorious if you want to develop
a morning habit and wake up earlier I'll
leave it in the description below but
for me this is a must I was not always a
morning person it was not something that
I enjoyed but the more I did it the more
I found that for me it's like gold my
kids usually wake up at 7 30 so these
two-ish hours are crucial for me they
allow me to wake up without feeling
rushed to be able to have time to be
still to pray to work on a YouTube video
I'm filming right now and it's 5 32 in
the morning well actually it was 5 32
when I started but all those sorts of
things that I can do for myself it's
it's my me time and I value that so much
because really my most productive and
peaceful hours of my day happened before
the sun rises I don't think that I would
get anything done if I did not wake up
early and third is I have learned not to
push myself more than I should and just
to slow down I talk more about that in
my video on why I quit the fire movement
I think that just Society in general
really values busyness I mean you ask
somebody how they're doing and more
often than not they'll say I'm busy and
for a long time I thought that this was
a good thing I thought that it meant
that I was hard working that my life was
was interesting and through my work as a
nurse especially in hospice nursing and
as a mom in general I just have come to
Value Stillness and slow intentional
living so much more in Spanish there is
a saying
that means if you try to do many things
your ability to do those things well
will be reduced I now make a priority of
my family and my health and sadly it was
not always that way I was the type of
individual that would just push push
push to get to this goal even at the
expense of burnout and my health and
that's just not the life that I want
anymore and that's not the life that you
deserve either you deserve rest and I
think that it's important to work and
it's important to do meaningful things
but we often forget the rest portion so
finding a happy medium between being
able to do those things but at the same
time making time for that rest and
making time for fun is huge so really
take inventory of all the activities
that you have either on a daily or
weekly basis and find which ones are
those priorities that you absolutely
should get done done or want to get done
and just cut out the ones where you can
and make time for that rest time for me
unfortunately that means that I cannot
post videos every single week at the
moment hopefully someday we'll be able
to get there for now it is every two
weeks but it is a goal it eventually
will happen I thank you for your
patience in the meantime though I
apologize that I rancid on this question
but in this ever busy world we live in I
think it's such an important topic to
talk about this next question is what
are my favorite apps for task management
oh I'm glad you asked this question
hands down Google Calendar is my
favorite app for task managing because
in the past I used to write my little
to-do list and I'd have my things of
what I wanted to do for that day or for
that week and more often than not they
would just happen tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow and push them down further why
because they were never scheduled and so
now I basically live by Google Calendar
and I schedule all sorts of to-do's like
if I have to go to the Post Office it's
scheduled at a specific time taking my
daughter to physical therapy okay that's
scheduled two all of those things I can
schedule on my calendar and be able to
see everything that I have to do and
then also not put too much on my plate
because I'm able to see all the things
that I have to do for that day so it
makes it more likely that I'm actually
going to be able to do them and it helps
me kind of prioritize what's more
important for which particular day also
I love the fact that I can color code
them so that it makes it much easier for
me to organize everything that I have to
do so for example my work days are in
red my YouTube videos and filming and
all those sorts of things are in green
any other kind of activities or if I'm
visiting someone I'll put them in a
different color it really just helps me
kind of visualize in a much more
organized way but also one of the things
that I really love about Google Calendar
is that you can share it because you
make an account you're able to share it
with individuals so if my husband wants
to edit something he has a dentist
appointment he can go in there and he
can edit it so hands down I love Google
Calendar and it's completely free and
then the next app that I use is really
just the notes app on my phone I used to
use Evernote especially for my recipes
if something would turn out good because
I would take a picture of my food and I
could put the picture and the
description on that but then it has a
paid for version and it was constantly
giving me the pop-ups asking me to
upgrade and I'm not all about that so I
just used the notes app on my phone
really for just any ideas that I get
especially like YouTube videos I have to
write them down because otherwise I will
forget so between these two things they
work out perfectly for me one is like an
agenda kind of organizing my day and
then the other is just I get a random
idea let's jot it down this last
question is a bit of a random one it is
do I have pets um actually no I used to
have a rabbit a long long time ago I
have chickens but those don't really
count I don't have any cats or dogs
actually I have a big fear of big dogs
my grandma was bit by a dog years ago
and I remember the wound vividly and
ever since then I've just always had
this major fear of big dogs and you
would think that as a home nurse after
the constant exposure I would have
gotten over this fear but only recently
it was about a month ago I was chased
down the street by one of my patients
dogs as I was about to enter the home
and let's just say that the anxiety
returned with a Vengeance and I really
wanted to quit my job that day my
co-workers make fun of me actually
because I'm always the person to type in
the notes they have a big dog make sure
make sure you know they have a big dog
my co-workers have told me that I should
probably just get a dog as a puppy and
that being a dog owner would help me and
I could see that I could actually
picture myself with a big fluffy dog
jogging down the street and I don't know
what else we would do probably cuddle it
would be fluffy that's one thing I know
it would be fluffy but first of all I
wouldn't even know what kind of a breed
to get so that's probably something that
would maybe maybe happen someday in the
future that's probably not going to get
scheduled on the Google Calendar
but what about you do you have any pets
and if you are a dog owner please I will
take all the tips that you can give me
on how to combat this it's rather silly
and embarrassing truthfully that is it
for today's video these are just a few
short questions but I hope I did not
rant too much and hopefully I provided
some value to you if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up and help
support my channel I thank you so so
much for your support and for taking
this time with me I can't wait to hear
from you in the comments and just learn
more from you and please let me know
what kind of suggestions you have for
future videos going forward I look
forward to hearing from you in the
comments and I'll see you in the next
video until next time bye for now